[Music]
let's go to samuel in each town where
i'm from what's up samuel
samuel you there
uh can you hear me there you are what's
up man
i'm doing well bless you i i've i've
heard you since your very first show you
ever aired really
yeah and i i'm telling i don't know if
it's because you're from houston but you
are just i mean you're so something
about your manner and the way you speak
is so familiar and it's just a piece of
home and it's h what it does it's
amazing i think so it's it's
listen if you want ever thought i think
i might want to go to houston but every
time i hear delony speak i want to put a
screwdriver in my ear you probably don't
want to move to houston because
i'm speaking for on behalf of the city
maybe no man thank you so much brother
it's good to talk to you and uh what's
up man how can i help
well i'm 30 i'll be 32 this year um i uh
this last year i have found
myself to be a single father to my three
kids
ages two four and six
um
i'm the exclusive parent um their mom
hardly ever sees them and uh
uh
i
lost my job two months ago
um
and so here i am uh the life i've built
was built around certain realities like
like you know a stable family and and a
certain trajectory and that that really
has all come to a
screeching halt i've looked back over
the last 10 years to just it's my if i'm
being honest my last 10 years is just i
feel like i've been putting out
fires just turn around and find a bigger
one and i'm coming to a point i'm
reaching a point where um i mean i have
good days and bad days and today i'm
okay but i feel like i'm always
this close just not not giving a rip i
don't i barely even know how anymore um
i'm just i'm losing the impetus to even
care i don't know how to explain it and
i don't know what i'm going to do next i
don't see what my future's supposed to
be yeah
and i i yeah
man so just brother brother i'm sitting
with you and i'm sorry i get i got
there's not a like a
cool saying that you know you'd cross
stitch and put on a bathroom wall or
something that's gonna make this feel
better and i'm sorry you know what i
mean sorry what happened to your
marriage man
you've been putting out fires for a
decade what happened
well i i i mean we our relationship was
really really toxic from the very very
beginning um that's not that's not even
remotely an exaggeration
and uh i thought i could save someone i
thought i could you know fix somebody
and she probably she probably thought
somewhat the same thing and we were we
were both toxic enough to you know
continue to spiral um i guess i guess we
felt we could both handle each other's
toxicity because we could both tear each
other apart and
kiss and make up in the next five
seconds and tear each other apart again
yeah
and uh i think that cycle just reached
ah i mean we both made awful decisions
throughout that marriage and i think it
reached ahead for her what does that
mean what does that mean
y'all both cheated on each other
yeah okay
uh was there addiction involved
uh i think i i i've
i'm gonna you know i don't like to admit
it i i've had a porn addiction for ten
years yeah okay all right
so why is mom not involved in her kids
lives
well she sees them every other weekend
and she's very happy with that
arrangement
she she's never i i've been the one
taking care of them even when we were
married for the most part um
she that's just
it's hard to explain i mean i don't it's
hard to explain she she's happy that
she's happy to kind of be the holiday
mom and take him to the beach and then
bring him back and
that's that she doesn't have an interest
in anything on that it's a pretty pretty
good arrangement right
um
for her yeah it's great i'm sure as i'm
saying i can't wrap my head around that
arrangement so what happened at work
brother
i was a really really really toxic uh
work environment i i
i worked for i've worked for the
catholic church for ten years
ah there you go and it just kind of just
got real i i maybe i shouldn't put it
that way but it just got really really
awful and toxic and uh
uh you know things were really really
mismanaged it was just awful management
and it just got from bad to worse and
eventually i was i was a church musician
okay i've been a trick musician for
forever okay
you know
so how are you how are you feeding you
and the babies right now
well i
i'm i'm i've took out a personal loan
and i'm
which i know is not smart and uh by next
month that's not gonna work and uh i i
live in friendswood we're gonna have to
move to be near my family in spring okay
um and uh which for those listening is
from you're in very south houston and
you have to move way north houston um
yeah and we're starting from the ground
up yeah yeah
um
man
so
a lot of you mentioned you're you're a
fixer you like to take care of other
people
um
you've got a history of infidelity
you've got a porn addiction
all those things point back to a history
of
someone who doesn't like who they see in
the mirror where did you learn that
where did you learn that you suck
i i
my
my parents um
fought like cats and dogs growing up
that was just normal i mean you know
three times a week just absolute
hysteria fits we were part of a
a very very uh rigid crazy religious
cult for 10 years growing up from about
age 10 to 19 where everything about you
was just wrong and evil and twisted
and so going into adulthood i really
believed everything about human beings
was just messed up and wrong um
i never fit in with anything i i
i couldn't just make normal friends or
have normal relationships um i never
just i never could get a
i mean i couldn't even get a girlfriend
it was awful it was really bad and then
you finally got one and you thought
well you had a model for what marriage
looked like man right yeah we had a
model for it which was let's have these
caustic wars
and then let's um
stick it out and figure it out and let's
keep making humans while we're having
these caustic wars that's the only
picture you had here's what i'm getting
at
um
if you and i were just having a drink
hanging out downtown houston somewhere
off kirby and we're just hanging out
i would look at you and be like dude you
made some stupid decisions and i would
smile at you right and you have
and
your pictures for what life is
is so jacked up
and you have a body
a little kid who is still trying to
still wondering what they're doing to
make mom and dad so upset
still wondering what is it about me that
god hates so much
and that
ultimately becomes the root of
i can't be in the same room with my wife
i've got these three little kids that
i'm thinking about cashing out on
that a cheap um
a cheap fake fantasy on my cell phone
with you know whatever
all of that points back to
man why do my parents hate me like what
about me as a six year old right all
that you've been carrying that crap
around forever
yeah and you chase it and you chase and
you chase it and now you found yourself
here man like
man
it caught up with you and so here we are
right and so now
i'll tell you this so back in grad
school um my professor
was one of the most astute assignments i
was ever given i challenge anybody
listening to this to do this
said i don't want you to write
uh like a mission statement because if
you're in this doctoral program you can
you can navigate words well you can
write something pretty and fancy and
poetic and whatever
i want you to draw a picture with like
matte pencils and crayons draw a picture
of your personal mission
and i'd never considered that and i sat
down with like i got some of my kids
stuff out and i drew it
and you know what the picture came like
that just came to me as i'm drawing and
again i'm a terrible artist like
comically so i look like i've got some
major like cognitive dysfunctions when i
try to draw a picture but the picture
ultimately was
a big
fire
probably a neighborhood or a city or
something and then a curb
and then me sitting on the curb next to
somebody
extending a lighter
well they've got a cigarette
and so i want you to picture me and you
right now we're just sitting on a curb
and everything behind you is on fire
and i'm handing you a light
and now we're going to try to figure out
what comes next
is that cool
yeah um some for some reason or another
i'm shaking a lot just having i don't
know
just hearing it but yeah okay
so here's a couple of things that i'm
gonna tell you to set the context for
what comes next
um first of all your body is
chemically addicted to stress to
cortisol adrenaline and beyond it has
been your entire life
and at some point those things those
chemicals think of them like drano right
they'll keep cleaning your you've heard
me say this before on the show they'll
clean a hair clog out of your pipes once
a year right you can get away with it if
you wake up every day and dump drano in
your pipes eventually it's going to eat
through the pipes
right and it's going gonna melt
everything that's where you're at
so number one you're gonna have to make
some decisions to detox from stress from
the chemicals that surge through your
body my guess is if there's not chaos in
your life you will make it
just so your body gets its hit is that
is that fair am i am i right
probably if work is going good you'll
come up with some some theological thing
or some something that the catholic
church did in ireland that you need to
have a fight about at work is that you
yeah okay and if something else if
that's not in the cards then you're
pissed off that they didn't get you the
right chords for your guitar what am i
right
okay
if your marriage is okay
you're gonna text that woman back you
know what i mean
things are okay i'm gonna i'm gonna text
her back and it's all cool it's just
cool and then she's like can i send a
picture and you're like your heart
starts beating fast and for one second
you feel alive and you say yes
yes am i right
yep okay
you have to commit for the sake of you
and those little girls that i'm going to
detox off stress which means i'm going
to have to learn
to live in peace and you've never had
that this is new you don't even have a
picture of what that looks like let me
paint it for you
imagine getting home from a job that you
mostly like nobody likes everything at
work i'm i live in a cartoon and i don't
like everything about my job
you'll get home
and you will play with your daughters
and you'll get onto one of them about
math and you'll tell one of them to pick
up her clothes and one of them's gonna
have a conversation with you about a
period and you're gonna be like what i
what you're gonna do all that
and then you're going to watch some dumb
show and you're going to read a book and
then you're going to do you're just
going to go the hell to sleep you're
going to go to sleep
can you even imagine
and then you're going to wake up and
you're going to have some crappy garage
gym because you can't leave because
you've got three kids and your single
dad and you're gonna go work out the
next morning right so that's what i mean
and you're gonna laugh and you're gonna
get a babysitter or mom's gonna pick up
you're gonna go grab a drink with some
buddies this i'm paying you a picture of
what this can look like
number two you're addicted to outburst
to these loud
demonstrative moments because you keep
everything so crashed inside of you
and hear me say this from this point
forward
yelling is trauma for a child never yell
again
got it
i don't know how but i mean i hear you
here's how never yell again
okay
you promise
i
i don't know yes you can here's what you
do today you're gonna take your
six-year-old and your four-year-old and
you're gonna sit him down and you're
gonna say
daddy's gonna start talking differently
in this house and i've scared you guys
and i've yelled and me and your mommy
yelled and i will never yell again
and now it's game on
and when you find yourself yelling you
will stop
and you'll say i'm so sorry who taught
you to yell your mom and dad
oh my god okay all the time so when i
say yelling is trauma you know that to
be true
yeah yeah
okay
so we're never gonna yell again
number three what have you done to look
for a job
mostly looked at what i'm
what is out there and it's
pretty slim slim pickings i mean it's i
mean if you're a 20 year old in college
it's awesome but
you know if you have time to work all
day 50 an hour but i i'll have to change
i i'm working it's been a series of
steps to realize just what the what the
what the parameters are and working with
that i'm still kind of
i've got a long term some long-term
ideas and some short-term realities and
and yeah it's kind of unclear all right
history all that stuff you just said
is grade a
choice downtown houston bs okay you have
to go get a job
you have to get a job and it's not going
to be your forever job it's going to be
something that begins to slowly and i'm
talking micro steps inch by inch give
you purpose back
and it's not going to be follow your
dreams bro none of that crap
it's going to be i am contributing to my
household because i got three little
girls
and i have a thing that i get up and go
do every day right now dude you are
caught on a loop
of what did i do what's going to happen
where is this thing headed
and it's going nowhere you got to go
somewhere
so i whether it's starbucks well i don't
care what it is you got to figure that
out but you got to get a job okay
then in two months five months six
months when your smoke clears on this
deal your divorce is finally settled
settled settled and you've moved to
spring you've got some sort of rhythm
then you can start saying okay what
comes next
and there's a million
people who work in ministry that get
laid off and go on to take those skills
the ones that you learned about empathy
putting on performance every week in
front of hundreds if not thousands of
people how to um
listen how to love people who are
struggling dude companies will pay
handsomely for your skill set you're
just gonna have to work through that and
that will take time that's not for today
though today is i gotta go get a job i
gotta start doing a thing okay and stop
stewing in my head about it got your
word on that we go get a job
okay anything i don't care what you're
making like you're anything will be more
than what you have right now
right here's the big one
you had a picture when you got married
that you were not going to be like mom
and dad am i right
yeah
yeah
and there's something catastrophic in
our souls when i swear
before god and all my friends and family
i will not be like you too
and then you look up 10 years later and
you're exactly like them if not worse
right
so here's the word you have to grieve
this
you gotta sit in it with a journal and
write it out
it's gonna hurt like hell it's gonna be
hard
it's gonna be painful
and there's a light on the other side of
that if you avoid this you will pass
this on to your three daughters and
they'll repeat this thing again
okay
okay
here's what it starts with
dear sam
thought things would be different and so
far they're not
period that's how your journal starts
here's the things i wanted to look
differently
here's the things that aren't different
and then as you're writing you're going
to start to incorporate here's what i'm
going to do about it
here's where things are going to be
different and over time you're going to
work with a counselor and you're going
to build that and build that and build
that
but slowly you're going to begin to let
your brain know sam's in charge for the
first time in my life how old are you
brother
yes 32 32. i fell apart at 36 35 no 30
35 34 35
okay
stone mad i took a seventy thousand
dollar household income pay cut went to
move to a new city with my wife and
young kid to try to figure things out
things worked out okay
all right
do you trust me on that
yeah okay
okay
little little little little little bitty
steps
if you lose your job the data tells us
that um it's as traumatic to your body
as
the death of a loved one
the trauma your body is screaming at you
we're not safe we're not safe we're not
safe you got to grieve that divorce
not safe not safe not safe it's trauma
your childhood trauma
your position right now terrified trauma
listen to me very carefully you're not
leaving those little girls are we on the
same page there
yes of course
are you gonna hurt yourself
um
no not not in potentially my my fear is
that i've i've never had ideation like
that and
about three months ago that happened for
the first time yeah you're tired
my guess is you don't want to be dead my
guess is you don't want to leave your
girls my guess is you want to stop
hurting right now is that fair
yeah yeah
i get that
do i have your commitment you're not
going to hurt yourself
yeah
yeah
say i promise i won't hurt myself
i promise i'll hold her muscle
and i'm in it for the long haul
okay i'm gonna repeat what i said to you
you're addicted to stress chemicals
that's gonna be a long-term play okay
you've gotta commit to
peace and it's gonna feel crazy for a
while you're gonna have to say things
like nope when your mind starts spinning
things up when you're about to text your
wife back to start a fight when you're
about to get mad at your parents for
whatever it is you gotta stop
okay
tell your people in your world that
you're doing this and let them call you
out cool
okay okay
and you're gonna grieve this thing and
grieve this thing do you have a
counselor you can talk to do you have
like male buddies in your life you can
reach out to
no i i i didn't i've made very little i
i've not been good at making male
friends okay and and i should just say
friends yeah that's cool
and hey
you got to own what happened to you
brother
you got to own it it happened and then
the here's the deal
you've spent your entire life trying to
edit old sentences from your childhood
from life from theologically all those
things
yes
those sentences have appeared at the end
you were abused you were traumatized you
were told god hates you if there even is
one right you were told your parents are
you told marriage looks like all that
stuff
there's a period at the end of those
sentences
and there's going to be a gap and that's
grief
and that's where that's where the
healing starts as after the forest fire
when the soil becomes as fertile as it
can possibly be
the smoke clears and the world is
raiding on you sam in houston
my new best buddy
what are you going to write next
all of this is what do you write next
okay
so
your commitment is you're gonna find
somebody whether it's at a local church
whether it's a counselor you're gonna
reach out i've actually you know what
hang on the line i'm gonna give you
three months at to betterhelp.com
therapy there okay i'm gonna hook you up
with it and it's all it's digital so you
don't even have to make an appointment
or arrangements for your girls you can
tell them to go sit in front of a screen
which i don't ever say that go sit in
front of a screen daddy's got um needs
to talk to somebody on the computer
and you can reach out and have somebody
walk alongside you until you get your
bearings straight okay until you can
find a permanent therapist up there in
spring where you're moving okay
and you you start with that journal
today
go to walmart and buy one for nine bucks
or five bucks or whatever it is buy a
spiral notebook for 99 cents i don't
care but we start today i want you to
hang on the line i'm gonna give you that
and i'm also gonna give you a copy of my
new book own your past change your
future
which is
that title's for you my brother right
now i'm with you every step of the way
here and i want you to call me back if
you ever need something do i have your
word on that
yes thank you i'll do that thank you all
right i want you to take a deep deep
breath as deep as you can and hold it
hold it one
two three now drop breathe it out
breathe all the way out and drop your
shoulders all the way down
today's the day it starts anew
okay
thank you
you're in
i'm in are you in
yeah
awesome